when you saw the trailer what was your
thought cake one miss grades have new
faces but their problems seem as
complicated as their predecessors look
at her in the eyes until you don't have
feelings Berg I don't use selfish
egotistical I just want to get in my car
and drive away and never come back
the new kids on the block how are we
feeling about entering this crazy world
of Vanderpump rules
anxious yeah anxious for sure yeah
definitely just excited but I don't know
I don't think we all know what's gonna
happen you know so what's making you
feel anxious I mean it's an established
show let's spit on four years and I'm
just curious to see what everyone's
reaction is gonna beat us and it's just
a new experience you just want to be
liked I mean I I I mean I'm already well
aware of what's really gonna happen you
know there's everyone has their the
people that don't like him and I think
he's got a really just embrace who we
really are in this show and and who are
in life and because that's what they're
filming they're feeling really us and
that's ya you guys right off the bat we
learned that there's a little something
going on between you two
how would you define your relationship
today um well she works for me at TomTom
again now so she's you guys friends
though no how was the relationship other
than work we're cool okay a cordial
friends though
don't grab drinks else how to work or
anything okay you're a great guy we're
gonna get to watch this all play out you
just like a bunch of people to validate
yourself let's not forget I hired you
here what would you say was kind of your
entry point to this preexisting group
though who are what was your way in I
mean I started I was working at TomTom
and then started working at Sur it was
just like I'm personally trained Lisa
and then working at the restaurant and
it all happened so fast is it like a
personal trainer Vanderpump I don't
think you can personal trainer better PO
I said keep your shirt on
take your travel
no she's just a god whether she calls
the shots you know like Rahzel de
blanco' type thing where it's just like
it's her way or the highway yeah guys
we're opening up Table five and have
lights on if it's not me it's gonna be
Lisa so to choose what you want
you are the boss at TomTom does that
make it difficult to navigate kind of
the friendship part of this group at all
um absolutely I mean it's even hard to
Swit Tom and Tom there's some things I
have to tell them like no we can't do
that I'm kind of torn sometimes but in
the end of the day I was kind of I've
got to make my own decision that guy
just do it and then I would rather just
like Ashley took for forgiveness instead
of asking you know
I'm shook it when you saw the trailer
and saw the first version of yourself
that's going to be presented to America
what was your thought is that me like
yeah damn damn in a good way or daemon
about I guess I get damn in like a
almost like a middle of that like good
or bad I'm in the middle right now and I
guess when I watch what happens I'll
you'll see which way the first trailer
they came out that showed the opening
titles like I didn't think we were gonna
see the opening titles until the show
came out and I was just like on the
floor it's like what is happening
getting to know this group who is the
easiest most open to new faces new
energy source for understand of all I
mean sure yeah Ariana everybody you know
and yeah Ariana for sure on the flip
side who was the least welcome Tina
scheana to me it was welcoming they'll
have a different take on that are you
guys dating already or scheana and I
actually have hooked up yeah as far as
like what hmm what's the difference here
I wonder is there a little bit of
jealousy my god Lisa I'm not jealous of
Dana are you 34 or he's 16 we see in the
trailer you guys have these kind of look
like blowup moments why was that such a
contentious relationship I mean that was
definitely from her end like she was
pretty cool to me up front and I can
speculate as to why I think that was
she'll say something different but she
seemed to have a problem with me pretty
quick off the bat and then after weeks
of me just taking it I finally didn't
want to anymore and then we kind of came
to a head and took a turn and became
better friends and like started over and
then some other things happen that
you'll see this season and you know
sounds like Vanderpump rules did you
guys watch the show before I watched the
first few seasons but then hadn't
watched like probably four through seven
okay I I caught a couple episodes I saw
scheana get married and then I remember
seeing another episode where she was
I guess that did away but like not
really not so much so I'm divorced I
don't if you know that no big deal
doesn't define me oh wow
yeah I only saw one episode like in
college I remember watching one and it
was like when Jax broke up with some
chick eating pizza Oh Carmen only
episode I watching that I don't even
know why or how I was watching that
who would you say brings more drama this
season oh gee cast are you guys I think
it's pretty equal right so I would say
it's like same same but different
because theirs is more deep-rooted and
this history that they have and I think
some long-term issues a lot more
invested in that people are invested in
and then ours is just happened
organically but is new and people
haven't seen that yet so I think there's
a lot on both sides
yeah the og cast seems to be talking
about this season like it is a big big
season for them I talked to them all at
Bravo Con and got all of them to give me
their take on the newbies
I'm gonna read quotes until you can
guess who said it and then I want to get
your reaction to we don't want them
around I don't really want them around
so they can go except for Maxum brain
I'm sorry I'll be honest
yep except for max and Bret sorry I'll
be honest Jax told he's a he detects
music I I I said I like you and Bret yes
you know I'm so fascinated by max I love
him like a brother I've only known him a
short period of time
he's funny charming witty he strikes a
perfect balance between being like just
easygoing and chill but also he has like
he's a really uh C he does things that I
could never do like fire people yeah I'm
so fascinated by max I love him like a
brother I've only known him a short
period of time
he's funny charming witty he strikes a
perfect balance between being like just
easygoing and chill but also he has like
piece of really see he does things I
could never do like fire people and
actually run a bar or it stays firing
people I would I'll be honest it looks
like they watched seasons 1 through 7 of
an
rules and just like reenacted everything
that we've already done
Nita voila you know stop see really you
know what I'll be honest it looks like
they watched seasons 1 through 7 of
Vanderpump rules and just like
re-enacted everything that we've already
done this is a to partner part 1 I think
they're all really hot so they fit in in
that way
definitely girl Kristin I'm gonna say
Kristin Kristin really I think they're
all really hot yeah no they fit in in
that way and someone interrupted her to
say this I don't think they're all that
hot some have not discovered Botox yet
Jeana you know some have discovered
Botox yet you know girl I mean some fit
in some don't you'll see that from the
first episode Sheena I'd say Jax or
Sheena I'm gonna go Jax I mean some fit
in some don't you'll see that from the
first episode I'm not gonna beat myself
up out there like this is fine there go
run in this hand was fine the nice ones
were all like I liked them so it's like
that's hard to write there's a lot of
like taking selfies and bikinis and
belfies and like they're like all day
long
I'm like can we have a conversation for
one second there's a lot of that it's
really hard for me to relate to 20 year
olds Jax Safi Oh Katie Stassi
so you love like taking like selfies and
bikinis and the belfies and like bit
like all day long I'm like can we have a
conversation for one second there
there's a lot of that it's really hard
for me to relate to 20 year olds so
hearing all of those general thoughts on
those clothes I think that everyone is
entitled to their own opinion
and I know the genuine relationships I
have with certain people and you can't
win them all so that's fine if they feel
that way and we'll just see how the
viewers feel I'm not worried about it
it's like people yeah they don't like
you don't like you if they like you I
mean that's yeah and it's got to keep
your head up I think we were all
ourselves and we're genuine to who we
are so that's what you're gonna see is a
reflection of that
so I'm excited I can't we see the
wrestle show thank you guys
first do you feel like something's been
lifted off now like Brice take your foot
off my throat yeah take your foot off
Oliver
yeah those Stassi quotes were brutal huh
[Music]